landre mort de noël de la place
pey-berland nous nous mettrons pas des
arbres morts seraient place de la ville
notamment sur la place le ballon gardé
souvenir de cet armement qu'en faisait
venir tous les ans donc c'est pas du
tout notre conception de la vegetal de
la végétalisation
en ce qui concerne les outils
réglementaires fin 2020 nous adopterons
ce qu'on appelle la charte des droits de
l'arbre qui est un règlement de
protection des arbres qui n'existe pas
donc d'ici à fin 2020 cette charte des
droits de l'homme sera adopté alors
chers chroniqueurs et de vous choquer ou
pas choqué par cette annonce du maire de
bordeaux plus de sapins de noël dans sa
ville et nous nous a rejoint nicolas
phalempin qui va avoir un rôle assez
difficile ce soir parce que le sens où
elle est minoritaire
vous avez trente trois ans vous êtes
militant écologique nous errons de
secrétaire régional de france nature
environnement grand est c'est bien sûr
vous soutenez la décision du maire de
bordeaux est ce que vous pourriez nous
présenter vos premiers arguments
est-ce que je ne pense pas non plus
totalement soutenir c'est ce que disait
monsieur hurmic
parce que j'expliquais simplement c'est
ya un problème de gestion des sapins de
noël tous les ans cinq millions de
français achètent à sapin pour deux
semaines et le jette à après les fêtes
c'est un problème en termes de gestion
de déchets en termes de gestion des
ressources que la vraie question c'est
pas la question du sapin de noël
on n'est pas là pour dire que les
français ne doivent plus s'amuser que
mes petits comprend un peu sale et il
faut qu'il faut être sérieux et ne juste
travailler ou ne pas faire la fête
non ce que ce se qui est derrière la
problématique du sapin c'est une
question plus vaste et celles d'une
société qui vise sur l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles active et même sur
la surexploitation de ses ressources
naturelles et tous les indices depuis
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années nous
montre que ce n'est plus possible de
vivre dans un modèle de surexploitation
d'accord et monsieur l'avant concon
abondent dans votre sang soo con
contredit ce jeu vous réagissiez quand
même à une déclaration que j'ai trouvé
un peu étonnant du maire de bordeaux
pierre hurmic
il a déclaré ceci autant l'opinion des
bordelais m'intéresse beaucoup
autant l'opinion des fachos de l'île de
strasbourg et de marseille je m'assieds
dessus
est-ce qu'on peut être contre sa
décision et ne pas être un facho à vos
yeux
parce que voyez je crois que assez peu
de fascistes dans l'équipe de balances
ton post l'after et pourtant les avis
sont partagés est ce que vous ne trouvez
pas que cette déclaration introduit le
débat sous un jour problématique
je ne suis pas en mesure de juger les
propos de mieux sur mitch vous ne
partagez pas je je n'aurais pas dit les
choses de cette façon
parfait le débat peut commencer donc
yann moix vous n'êtes pas choqué c'est
en fait c'est pas tellement la question
la question c'est que c'est ridicule qui
voulait et je vais vous dire ce qui me
fait une chose qui me choque c'est la
suivante
oublions pour l'instant parce qu'on va y
revenir sans doute dans le débat que
noël soit une fête religieuse
on met ça juste non mais ça viendra dans
le déjà vous avez raison mais il ya une
chose qu'on ne peut pas oublier c'est
que noël est une fête pour les enfants
et je trouve que l'appellation d'arbres
morts pour le jour où les enfants se
retrouvent en famille où les enfants
vont aller sous cet arbre mort pour
aller chercher des cadeaux le rappeler
que l'homme est mortelle à une époque où
ils croient encore au père noël
c'est non seulement de très mauvais goût
d'une part mme rajouterai faut que les
arbres morts sont excellents pour la
biodiversité d'autre part et que mettre
le mot mort pour des gens qui veulent
juste commémorer la naissance d'un
enfant d'une part ou d'autres qui
veulent juste avoir sous l'arbre mort
pensant à tout sauf à la mort c'est le
seul privilège qu'on a quand on est
enfant eh bien je trouve que un maire
qui choisit de faire sonner le mot de
noël avec un roulant de mobilité est
quelqu'un qui aurait mieux fait
peut-être d'aller faire un tour en forêt
cette fois avant de sortir une phrase
aussi morbide bonbons -
ça a le mérite d'être clair phalempin
obligé de vous poser la question est ce
que on a affaire à une mesure écologique
ou à une mesure laïque est ce que c'est
une offensive contre un aspect de noël
qui est à la fois célébré par des laïcs
et des religieux
est-ce qu'on voulant supprimer ce
symbole vous voulez plus de laïcité dans
la république française par c'est pas la
peine de dire nous moi je ne m'exprime
pas au nom de monsieur remis que je
m'exprime pas au nom donné en tant
qu'étoile jr dont il aimait logist est
ce que c'est votre avis non mais moi ce
que je veux dire ce qu'il faut peut-être
reprendre le débat à l'origine il faut
se rappeler que cette déclaration a été
extraite d'une conférence de presse
qu'il a fait jeudi le jeudi 10 septembre
je crois qui a duré deux heures et deux
de cette conférence de presse de deux
heures on en a extrait une séquence de
30 secondes séparent la question
bienvenue au gré des déclarations il
n'en est rien
il a dit qu'il allait renforcer la
sécurité à bordeaux-ii d'accord ronde et
à renfort de challancin je vous demande
c'est une offensive recto logique où une
offensive laïque
pas la peine de me dire qu'il a parlé
deux heures je le sais oui comme au
graff a commenté les deux heures je vous
repose la question est ce une offensive
écologique ou 9 ans if make
est ce qu'un une arrière-pensée or là
encore je crois que vous vous trompez de
jeu ne trompe pas je pose la question je
trouve qu'elles ont uniquement le sapin
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt de
problèmes beaucoup plus graves
mais vous vous en pensez quoi monsieur
semaine non monsieur phal ont pas je
pense que puis il faut réguler la
manière de fall la manière dont on voit
le sapin de noël qui a peut-être une
solution entre le sapin synthétique des
le sapin jetables on peut trouver une
solution plus durable
on peut par exemple proposer des sapins
repos mais nous est sûre c'est l'urgence
en 2020 c'est vraiment ce que c'est
vraiment l'urgence écologique il faut
bien commencer par quelque chose mais
pas rigoler ce qu'il faut commencer par
ça alors je baille urgence climatique
la convention citoyenne pour le climat a
rendu ce sont ces propositions il ya
trois mois
lune l a fait 150 propositions
seul qui a été retenu vraiment par le
grand public c'était la volonté de
limiter la vitesse maximale sur
autoroutes à 110 km/heure voulait pas
répondre à la question
pourtant c'était une mesure elle il y
aurait pu faire économiser 2 millions de
tonnes de co2 moyennes
non je tente une dernière s'en voulait
pas répondre à la question je possède
moi je pose la question jusqu'à ce que
j'ai la réponse facile un peu de jeu
repose à monsieur ça non pas monsieur
phalempin est ce une offre est ce une
offensive écologique ou laïcs
alors est ce que est ce que pour vous il
devrait y avoir plus de laïcité dans la
république française
alors à titre personnel je tenais et non
mais j'ai beau énormément d'amis
écologistes et énormément de croyants
par mieux d'accord donc on a la victoire
à me mettant dans le vent traditionnel
on s'approche on s'approche je pense que
monsieur est assez honnête dans sa
démarche parce qu'il a vraiment une
vision écologiste pour le coup qui n'est
pas celle du maire justement parce que
la vision du maire n'est ni écologique
ni laïque elle est politique c'est à
dire que europe écologie les verts sont
dans la destruction des racines mêmes et
de tout ce qui constitue la france
effectue un républicain laurent jahier
vous savez je vous promets vous prenez
ça n'a rien à voir je parle de de la
décision de se mesurer
donc c'est ni écologique ni laïque ces
politiques lorsqu'on remarque dans les
diverses décisions qu'ils ont prises ces
dernières semaines notamment avec le
tour de france
et caetera qu'il touche à tout ce qui
constitue les racines même de la france
et ce qu'aiment les français regardez
les sondages qui sont sortis sont ses
sujets environ deux tiers des français
sont contre ces position d'europe
écologie les verts parce que les
français sont attachés aux sapins au
tour de france à tout ce qui constitue
nos habitudes et nos traditions et
europe ecologie les verts et dans cette
destruction des traditions donc c est je
vais répondre à votre question il me
semble politique pour moi c'est une
démarche politique parce qu'ils sont
justement dans la même démarche de
déstabilisation de tout mais tout ce qui
constitue les racines françaises